encore du rêve et des gros sous cette
fois c'est canal+ qui vient de s'offrir
pour trois ans l'intégralité des
retransmissions des matchs de la ligue 1
de football
le prix de cette exclusivité 600
millions d'euros en moyenne par saison
un très gros investissement au détriment
de tps la filiale de tf1 et m6 ce soir
d'ailleurs le pdg de tf1 estime esprit
totalement déraisonnable alain dorgans
même base le canal + sur la ligue 1 pour
1,8 milliard d'euros durant la période
2005 2008
canal+ en concurrence avec le bouquet
satellite tps et france telecom a
remporté la totalité des quatre lots
pour 600 millions d'euros en moyenne par
an la saga sportive préférée des
français depuis vingt ans canal+ de la
partage avec tps depuis 1999
aujourd'hui canal + se trouve dans une
situation de monopole qu'elle avait
connu depuis sa création en 1984
jusqu'en 1999
canal+ de son côté a mis en avant non
seulement son expérience mais aussi son
fort souci d'innovation technologique et
là ce sont des choses qui certainement
ont joué un rôle important dans la
décision
la ligue 1 devient une des plus chères
d'europe elle dépasse la première league
anglaise qui rapporte en angleterre
1,638 milliard d'euros sur trois ans le
football a gagné ce soir et je dois vous
dire que j'en suis fier car depuis deux
ans et demi j'ai foi dans nos clubs et
j'ai foi dans le championnat de france
je pense qu'ils étaient sous-évalués
nous sommes en train de rattraper un peu
le retard que nous avions par rapport à
nos concurrents européens
le football va coûter 11 re par mois et
par abonné à canal+ tandis que le cinéma
ne coûtera que 2,40 euros en dépit de ce
déséquilibre
le groupe canal+ estime avoir réalisé
l'investissement industriel stratégique
qui permettra d'améliorer la
valorisation aux yeux des actionnaires
de vivendi universal la maison
r
[Musique]